(Playing Hello by Adele)
fart
Doesn't tear you a-fart.
That's what I wish was that lyric.
[Intro]
Hi guys, my name's Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now!
It is Friday here on the it'sGrace Channel.
It's time to comment on your comments
Let's (sigh) proceed.
I was going to say do it, but that seems sexual.
I don't like lingering sexual tension with my audience
Let's start over on Twitter, ever heard of it (depressing laugh)?
e_e_Short
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
For all of those who do not know, when a new person comments on one of my social media platforms
I GRACE the crap out of them and welcome them to the it'sGrace family.
How do I know if it's a new person?
I don't know I just guess everyone is new
Ooooooh! This looks like I literally took a picnic table cloth and made it into a shirt.
e_e_Short more like pee pee long
I hope that you are so hydrated that you peeeee and pee  for a long time
I hope your urine isn't this color because woof. Welcome to the club.
Dehydrated AF.
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"My friend is working at a daycare this summer. She used this amazing image to describe it. @gracehelbig"
Whoa
One, your friend has a bad summer job.
Two, this is me and I have no recollection of what this is from
Did I kidnapped for a period of time that I'm not recalling?
Did I vlog it? Because that'd be great click bait.
Am I in a closet? Am I opening a door?
Is there a slow-mo bullet coming near my face?
I don't understand. Am I in a wooden shower?
Which sounds like a terrible sexual position.
I don't know what's happening here, but I'm glad I can be a tool for your friend to express her emotion.
Frankiematonx
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
Frankiematonx more like Frankie kneel on pee.
You did your yoga directly into piss puddle that e_e_Long-- short, e_e_Short left.
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"You made it into a Lily Allen tweet, gwan big yourself up."
Whoa.
Couple of things
"gwan big yourself up." That sounds like I'm a man with a penis who you're telling me to go masturbate.
But I believe that's something about "give yourself some credit."
Cool
Second of all, yeah Lily Allen tweeted, "What if the Russians killed all the famouses that died in 2016 to distract us from hacks."
And used a GIF of me looking confused.
Someone GIF those last couple of seconds
There's another GIF that she can add to her library to use.
That's great. I think Lily Allen really (belches) cool.
KimBarboo
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
KimBarboo more like KimBoobs.
It's a rough day for Gracey
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"Reading the comment section of a gracehelbig video is an dot dot dot experience."
No sh(cymbals crash)t.
And I love it.
Now let's go to Instagram. Every heard of hit (less depressing laugh)?
csterwart12345
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
cstewart12345 more like "See Steward? One, two, three, four, five
of the other five guests at this party think that you are
(softly) awful."
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"Are those like your only friends cause it looks like it."
Well at least my friends are more bubbly than yours
Yes, they are my only friends.
conormcgriddle
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
conormcgriddle more like you sound like a fuckboy or an Irish McDonald's breakfast sandwich.
Two things people make the mistake of hanging out with when they're very, very drunk.
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"I most definitely do not want to see this."
You know, being in the digital space for so long, a lot of people ask how I would describe my audience base.
And I always say reluctant, irritated, agitated, blunt, cute!
bazinga_2007
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
bazinga_2007 more like Jim Parsons 2017--
he got married. He got married in 2017 and it was beautiful.
I have the photos I saw. I was not invited.
No, no, no. He's too good of a human for me to be physically in his presence for the length of a wedding.
(laughs)
What?
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"SHE. LOOKS. BETTER. THAN. I. DO. ON. A. NORMAL. BASIS. AKA. AMAZING."
Are you a doge that learned how to type as if to personify a very specific vocal cadence?
And you're a fan of the Big Bang Theory? Wow.
Doge, you've got culture, you've got class, you've got style, you've got your ass is probably hanging out.
crazyprincess
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
crazyprincess more like sanepeasant.
Yeah. That's usually how it goes.
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"goose has the most judgemental eyes ive ever seen on a dog."
Well, let's see what she thinks about that
Grace: Oh my God, you're adorable.
janatamer5
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
janatamer5 more like "Jana, tame your five fingers in class. Stop masturbating openly in class."
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"Omg what did you do to your dog cry face emoji cry face emoji by the way she looks so good."
Um, I just loved her, and took care of her, and nurtured her.
And then I put a dress on her, and I exploited her for my own social media gain, and I felt guilty about it, and I took it off, and just put a regular t-shirt on her
which is still slightly exploited it, but not so aggressive.
My social media gained nothing.
Now let's go to YouTube ever heard of it (self-disappointing look).
Az B
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
Az B more like ass butt. Ass is a butt, but are all butts asses?
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"In the 6 years I've been watching you do things on the internet, I've seen you do some really dumb things."
"But this may be the dumbest thing of all. This is the pinnacle of your dumbness. Don't change, I love it."
Please don't tell me I'm peeking in my dumb right now.
because I can get dumber, you guys.
Don't challenge me to get dumber, because I can get dumber.
I will get dumber.
I will dumb the f(cymbal crash) down.
Don't you dare tell me I've out down myself, 'cause I will dumb it hard--
I will--
I will be so dumb.
Subscribe to my YouTube channel!
awesomeabnormality
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
awesomeabnormality more like "Awesome abs Nor McDonald!"
is a phrase I will probably never say out of this room
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"Grace's mother could 100% be one of those crazy swedish-british people, tall and beautiful JUST SO GOD DAMNED CHARMING."
This is a very specific category for my mother to be in.
Are there other "those"?
Korina Loya
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
Korina Loya more like Korina Lawyer. I'm gonna sue you so lawyer up. I'm gonna sue you for being so engaged with my content.
I'm not gonna sue you, I'm gonna applaud you.
(extremely weak, inaudible applauds)
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"I watched this last night very drunk, and I, for some reason, thought I was watching this on a CD, and that it was scratched every time those repetitive edits played."
"I literally paused the video, took the CD out (I was watching Blades of Glory, lol), cleaned it, and forgot to put it back in without realizing."
When the edits happened again, I got really frustrated, and was confused when I tried to take the CD out and it wasnt there.
I woke up with it stuck to my shoulder. I'm only a little embarrassed.
Korina, wow. No one should have to live like the way you've been living.
Thank you for telling your story. You're very brave, and I hope you inspire a lot of other people out there that might be dealing with the same thing
because no one should live like this.
No one should own Blades of Glory on a CD
Okay! That's it for commenting on your comments this week.
Thank you guys so much for commenting across all my social media platforms.
If you don't know already, I'm @gracehelbig across the board.
Give this video a thumbs up if you like these types of videos and subscribe to this YouTube channel
because it's a great channel says someone out there, unrelated to me by blood.
I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday sometimes. Other than that, I don't know.
brielovespuppies
NEW PERSON NEW PERSON NEW PERSON
brielovespuppies more like cheese loves puppies, but do puppies love cheese?
No, not good for them
Ooohh. My brain broke in that one
YOU'VE BEEN GRACED
"I feel like grace has finally lost it."
Oh, nope!
I found it